it's nasty
herles smer wants to save
him I have my orders too sir they don't
include me abandoning my post I
understand that but this changes things
why my name Richard because you're
getting on that plane I don't understand
what about you I'm staying here with him
till the plane gets safely
away I'm your older brother Mike and I
was stepped over that's the way pop
wanted it it ain't the way I wanted
it I can handle things I'm
smart I'm laughing at
so dark up
above the sun's in my heart and I'm
Ready for
Love on your friends and always keep
your mouth
shut as far back as I could remember I
always wanted to be a
gangster
hey Mom what do you think you look like
a
gangster
w
he started the war but do you think if
it hadn't been for Mr Kane the United
States would have the Panama Canal
Charles Foster Kan is nothing more or
less than a communist Kane Governor
listen when the voters of this state and
Mrs Kan learned what I found out about
Mr Kane and a certain little Blondy
named Susan Alexander he couldn't be
elected dog catcher I'm going to skin Mr
Charles Foster Kane
alive
oh
w